blm racked up another dead body
of people killed by the blm riots
the star tribune in minneapolis reported
that they found a charred body
of an unidentified man within the
wreckage of a minneapolis pawn shop
on monday this was following the
torching of that establishment
at the end of may the man who was found
dead is
chuck horton jr 43 year old black male
oh i'm sorry that's another death sorry
there were two deaths the first one was
in the pawn shop
killed by blm rioters the second one is
chuck horton jr
43 year old black male who lay on the
sidewalk in front of the cadillac pawn
shop
with a gunshot wound to his torso he was
not breathing
a crowd of noisy protest
protesters gathered around but they
didn't help him
they just put him on video with their
phones and speculated about what took
place
all those wonderful peaceful protesters
watched a man
who had been killed by the riots
bleeding out
dying on the sidewalk actually it was a
cop who knelt down by the man
and performed cpr while a second cop
waved off the protesters who were not
only doing nothing
they were streaming the death of a man
on
on the internet but the cops are the bad
guys and the peaceful riders are the
good guys
that's that's a conspiracy theory
where's that one does that one get
kicked off twitter i don't think so
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you